pues las medidas sanitarias son
básicamente esta mascarilla que es
obligatoria absolutamente para todas las
personas que sean personas por parte de
la logística de los equipos pero también
para el público sobre todo aquí en niza
que estamos en una zona roja donde el
virus circula activamente en la francia
habrá un ambiente diferente porque no
habrá autógrafos con los corredores
tampoco habrá oportunidad de tomarse
fotos con ellos no habrá posibilidad de
darles la mano así que todos se hacen a
distancia también incluso para la prensa
pues hay restricciones para por ejemplo
hacer las entrevistas muchas de ellas se
van a hacer a distancia o habrá que
hacerlo con un boom para tener el
micrófono al menos unos dos metros de
distancia esas son las medidas y un
aforo de cinco mil personas no habrá
además público ni en la línea de llegada
ni en la línea de salida en ninguna de
las etapas así que esas son todas las
medidas que se han hecho aquí y
claramente pues además los equipos están
protegiendo muchísimo a sus corredores
este año por ejemplo cada corredor tiene
una habitación para él solo y ya no
están compartiendo precisamente para
evitar
a evitar mayores contagios en caso sobre
todo de que haya un caso positivo de
ccoo y 19 como usted bien lo decía el
equipo puede ser excluido si hay dos
casos positivos en el espacio de siete
días